[Musique]
est-ce que j'ai vraiment besoin
d'expliquer de quoi on va parler
aujourd'hui
ou alors je lance justin trop un voilà
[Musique]
il salua tous les amis c'est françois
pour la gêne explique mme encore je suis
ravi de vous retrouver une nouvelle fois
sur cette chaîne
aujourd'hui on va parler de deux caméras
plutôt sympa dont on parle beaucoup et
qui sont assez abordable la gopro héros
cette black edition est la toute petite
et sympa dit gerry osmose ok alors avant
toute chose je tiens à vous dire que ce
sera pas du tout un test scientifique là
je vais vous donner vraiment mon avis
sur la question sur ses deux caméras et
sur le fait que ce soit ou pas des
gadgets ou de vraie caméra mais par
contre il ya de très bonnes vidéos qui
ont été faites sur les détails
techniques sur toutes les
fonctionnalités et je voulais mais en
descriptions il ya vraiment des trucs
super bien fait pour l'idée ici c'est
vraiment de vous donner mon avis sur ses
caméras sur ce qu'on peut en faire sur à
qui elles sont destinées et à quoi elles
sont destinées
et bien sûr ça ne reste que mon avis ce
n'est pas une vérité absolue bien sûr
c'est juste un avis hein comme
l'indiquent parce que dans tous les cas
ces deux caméras sont hyper
intéressantes elles ont des points forts
qui sont assez hallucinant elles ont
aussi des points faibles et on va en
parler tout de suite feu goce est parti
alors la première chose à savoir sur ces
deux caméras c'est que la communication
des marques a été faite de telle sorte
qu on les oppose souvent on les met un
peu en concurrence alors que m'a pas du
tout sont des caméras qui ont deux
philosophies complètement différentes et
qui sont aussi destinés à des
utilisations différentes alors première
chose on va enfoncer des portes ouvertes
un la gopro 07 c'est une action cannes
et donc comme son nom l'indiqué elle est
prévue pour filmer dans tous les sens un
peu n'importe comment dans n'importe
quelles conditions
voire même les conditions les plus
extrêmes en plus de ça il ya toute une
tonne d'accessoires générique qu'on peut
y greffer pour les fixer à peu près
partout et faire des plans un peu what
the fuck dans n'importe quelle condition
et ça c'est pas une nouveauté mais les
gens ont un petit peu tendance à
l'oublier quand il la compare à l'osm au
pocket parce que a contrario l'osm aux
croquettes elle ça reste une petite
caméra sur une nacelle électronique qui
résistera je pense très mal aux chocs et
qui va pas du tout du tout qui fait la
flotte par exemple donc déjà si vous
êtes sportif si vous êtes aventuriers si
vous amenez votre caméra dans des
endroits un petit peu
regarde dangereux mais des endroits où
il se passe des trucs comme un petit peu
violent c'est clair que le choix il est
déjà fait un x aller vers la boue pro
ensuite un terme de rendu d'image moi je
suis assez d'accord avec les comparatifs
qui ont été faits même si les deux
caméras ont un mode flat côté bo pro on
va avoir ce qu'on appelle pro tune est
cotée au mot on va avoir le dessiner
like qui a été ajoutée dans la dernière
mise à jour là si vous l'avez pas fait
fait le parce que c'est un gros plus
mais malgré ça la bo pro elle a quand
même un rendu beaucoup moins birol est
beaucoup moins cinéma on est d'accord
que ce terme ne veut absolument rien
dire mais que vous m'avez parfaitement
compris justement parce que la gopro est
une action une cave du coup elle a une
focale j'ai quand même beaucoup plus
large et même si on peut utiliser un
mode qui va réduire un petit peu le
champ de vision ça reste quand même
assez déformé et on a quelque chose qui
est vraiment très typé pour avoir le
champs de vision maximum est de ce point
de vue là c'est plutôt l'osm au pocket
qui va remporter le point selon moi
parce que on va avoir une focale plus
serré et qu'on va avoir beaucoup moins
de déformation est donc une image plus
fidèle à la réalité
après pour ce qui est de la qualité
globale des deux caméras franchement
j'ai envie de dire c'est relativement de
l'enculage de mouchin puisque les
capteurs sont quand même tout petit
c'est grosso modo la même chose avec des
petits plus dans certaines conditions
chez l'un ou chez l'autre mais on n'est
pas non plus sur une différence
flagrante
moi j'ai pas personnellement de
préférence c'est surtout un choix
artistique un choix visuel est ce qu'on
va vouloir quelque chose qui est très
grande avec ce ce côté cheap et de la
gopro qui est un petit peu déformé ou
quelque chose de plus réaliste on va
dire avec l'osm au pocket qui va être
plus serré l'autre point sur lequel on
compare beaucoup ces caméras c'est la
stabilisation alors de la part de dj moi
j'en attendais pas moins
dee jay fait de supers stabilisateur
c'est vraiment une référence dans ce
monde-là donc forcément osmo pocket
allait bénéficier de toute la qualité de
stabilisation que peut avoir un
stabilisateur dj la petite nacelle
répond nickel le faith tracking est
super bon là dessus rien à dire c'est
hyper stable c'est hyper smooth c'est
une tuerie mais j'ai envie de dire on
sent bits est un petit peu alors que la
gopro elle est stabilisé optiquement et
logiciellement parlant donc il n'ya pas
de stabilisateur mécanique dessus et là
c'est juste ahurissant de fluidité j'ai
été plus bluffé par la stabilisation de
la gopro même si on n'est pas aussi
smooth que sur deux dj mais on n'est pas
dans la même utilisation que par ben
justement ce game boy qui est finalement
assez classique même s'il reste très
très bon alors attention sur la gopro
n'est pas sur une guibole on n'est pas
sur un stabilisateur mais en même temps
c'est pas le but lavaud pro elle est
faite pour être secoués dans tous les
sens pour être bougés pour être dans des
environnements où ça secouait ou alors
où elle doit être a placés à des
endroits un petit peu what the fuck
et même s'il a beaucoup rire aussi
c'était qui permet un stabilisé quand
moi je me rappelle des gourous euros 3 à
4,5 juste dégueulasse à certains moments
on pouvait vraiment rien faire des
rushes parce que ça se contrôle à
vraiment on élimine complètement le
problème il ya des gens qui ont fait ça
ce jet ski on a l'impression que le
machin il est sûr vraiment sur un game
boys et c'est ouf c'est je trouve que la
prouesse technique elle est plus du côté
de go pro que du côté de dj mais là
encore ces deux usages ces deux
philosophies complètement différente
après il ya tout ce que j'appelle les
phisheurs un petit peu gadget comme les
hyper l'absout les trucs du genre
bon on va pas s'attarder forcément là
dessus dans les vidéos que vous et
misant description vous trouverez toutes
les infos dont j'ai besoin là dessus
personnellement c'est pas des trucs dont
je vais me servir beaucoup
voire même pas du tout parce qu bosse
pas vraiment mon délire là dessus mais
ça peut être le vôtre c'est pas
forcément je pense ce genre de fille
turquie va devoir décider ou motivé
votre choix parce que c'est les usages
les plus courants qui vont être
intéressant plutôt que d usage ponctuel
donc grosso modo pour faire votre choix
entre les deux si vous hésitez encore on
va dire que la gopro elle est utilisée
plus si vous voulez lui met sa race 1
on va dire ça comme ça alors que
l'ossement pocket ça va être une
utilisation un petit peu plus posé un
petit peu plus réfléchis pas forcément
dans l'action quelque chose qui va être
pensé avant mes plans un petit peu plus
recherchés on va dire on va avoir plus
de temps on va avoir plus un côté encore
une fois avec d'énormes guillemets plus
un côté cinéma mais du coup faut
répondre quand même à la question est ce
que ces caméras ce sont des petits
gadgets high tech ou est ce que ce sont
des vrais caméra alors déjà le rapport
qualité prix est bon dans un cas comme
dans l'autre on va avoir des images de
qualité on va avoir quelque chose qui
tient la route mais moi je vois
plusieurs cas de figure le premier c'est
vous voulez vous acheter votre première
caméra vous n'avez pas forcément un
budget de ouf
vous pouvez très bien partir sur une
hausse moreau ou sur une groupe pro en
fonction des utilisations est ce qu'on
m'a dit juste avant
l'avantagé c'est que ça prend aucune
place qu'on peut le dégainer ses du run
and gun quand on dit est vraiment c'est
de bonnes images vous allez pouvoir
sortir des bonnes choses avec le
deuxième cas de figure dans lequel ça
pourrait vous intéresser si vous avez
déjà un boîtier avec des objectifs
interchangeables et que vous cherchez
une petite caméra d'appoint ou quelque
chose que vous pouvez sortir peut-être
plus facilement plus rapidement selon
vos besoins ballack la main ça peut
faire une deuxième caméra qui peut être
une caméra complémentaires mais
attention le rendu sera quand même pas
le même mais pour finir par contre même
si ces caméras sont juste dingue et
qu'au niveau technologie c'est une pure
tuerie
vraiment on reste très très loin de ce
qu'on peut faire avec un reflex ou un
hybride abstention gx 82 panasonic qu'on
trouve dans les 500 balles d'occasions
par exemple quand même en être conscient
faut pas se dire j'ai une hausse
moquette rouge et un nouveau procès ben
pélops le roi du pétrole marche pas
comme ça en terme d'image en termes de
plage dynamique en termes de gestion des
basses lumières rien à voir mais comme
je vous le disais en première caméra ou
en caméra d'appoint aucun souci ça fera
le job n'y aura pas de problème c'était
donc ma petite réflexion sur ses deux
caméras ça faisait longtemps que je
voulais en discuter avec vous
en parler parce que notamment à noël ma
moitié m'a gentiment offert l'autre pour
get qui est vraiment super sympa avec
laquelle je m'amuse beaucoup et albert
ii s obstiner dont on est le lien en
descriptions m'apprêtais la gopro eros
est donc c'était l'occasion de faire un
petit comparatif entre les deux même si
pour le coup c'est pas un comparatif
mais plutôt juste mon avis sur ces
caméras donc voilà les amis c'est tout
pour aujourd'hui j'espère que cette
vidéo vous aura plu si c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas comme d'habitude à m le
traditionnel coup deux blaster sur le
pouce en l'air qui se situe juste en
dessous de cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas non plus à vous abonner si
c'est pas déjà fait comment départager
laïque et fait du bruit
et puis comme d'habitude rester curieux
et à très bientôt pour une prochaine
vidéo
sinon si on parle de taille là on va
parler dans prochaine vidéo un petit
teaser de cette espèce d'énorme au
machin j'en ai quelques uns sous la main
on va être sur autre chose
1 place est un objectif la semos mot
pocket mois la voilà juste pour utiliser
un petit peu sur la prochaine vidéo